welcome welcome welcome what a day of
news I'm going to be talking about a
whole bunch of different stuff today
there are multiple new investigations I
want to tell you about I'll just give it
a minute or two to let people connect
and get on the stream I was just
watching on my phone a bunch of people
were texting me about yesterday's
interview with the extraordinarily
homophobic Paul Cameron and it's so
funny because I used to have these
homophobes on the show more frequently
when gay marriage was being more heavily
debated and there were a lot of these
sort of prominent homophobes and I
stopped doing it for the most part
because the a lot of the issues that
they were talking about have more or
less been resolved like we know that
children who were adopted by gay parents
do just as well as children adopted by
straight parents adjusting for whatever
factor caused them to be in the market
for being adopted in the first place I
hate to use the word in the market but I
don't mean for sale obviously I mean
just in an environment where they they
could be adopted bans on same-sex
marriage have now been made it
prohibited by the Supreme Court decision
in 2015 so I had Paul Cameron back
yesterday because I wanted to just sort
of get a sense from him of do you feel
like you've lost he's 79 years old now
do you feel as though your life's work
has gone to nothing effectively and he
did filibuster me a lot and there's a 35
minute interview on our YouTube channel
which I encourage you to check out with
Paul Cameron and anyway people were
texting me about there were particular
really crazy things that he said that
when I was in the moment trying to parse
everything he does this gif Gallup where
he just throws so much crazy stuff at me
that sometimes I don't realize until I
look back at the almost like funny
nature of some of the things he said and
I was just watching it back myself and
just kind of chuckling because there's
just so much so much craziness
these homophobes are still obsessed with
and it's just so sad and I know that I
don't just feel sad for them because
they ruin so many people's lives via
their homophobic activism but I do feel
bad that they have devoted their lives
to something that they've just lost
right I mean I know that in some states
you can still be fired for being gay and
we're working on that of course there is
all sorts of implicit bias that still
exists but on the legal side every year
there are victories for LGBT rights as
there should be and the cognitive
dissonance is just very strong so if you
didn't see that go back and check out my
interview yesterday with Paul Cameron ok
so this is a live stream if you've never
seen one of my live streams before they
get very crazy people troll all sorts of
stuff goes on and it's a great time for
the most part we are going to be taking
questions and comments via super chat
super chat is triggered for lack of a
better term by the dollar symbol at the
bottom of the chat window if you have
something you want to ask me that you
want me to answer on stream if you have
a comment you want me to read there is
no faster way to get that in front of me
and on screen we will put Super chats on
screen then using the dollar sign at the
bottom of the chat window I am open to
taking some phone calls if people want
we want 10 new members that's what we've
been doing if 10 people sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership i will thank
you during the stream and then i will
open up the phone lines and things get
crazy on the phone lines sometimes
people are very angry with me and that's
fine i don't screen them if people want
to confront me about all of the things
i'm ignorant on that's exactly what the
phone lines are for if you want the
phone lines opened take advantage of
membership please don't troll the live
chat I'm paying some attention and we
have a moderators who are paying
attention do not troll the live chat and
lastly you can use the join button right
below the video window to become a
YouTube channel member that counts
towards the 10 new members that we are
looking for a one other thing to mention
and then
we'll get on with it there is so we hit
600,000 subscribers on our YouTube
channel a few days ago and to celebrate
this we are doing something called 64 60
meaning 60 memberships at 60% off
because we have achieved the milestone
of 600,000 YouTube subscribers if you
want to get a 60% off discount off of a
membership on our website use the code
sixty four sixty that's 6-0 for6 zero
sixty percent off that makes a yearly
membership two bucks a month it makes a
monthly membership two dollars and forty
cents a month it's a great deal and
it'll get the phone lines opened to
sweet I think is the term that I am
looking for okay so let's get into the
news and we're gonna get into all of
this stuff extensively on the program
tomorrow election 2020 is going to be
investigations okay so Donald Trump is
starting to think about how can I get
myself reelected the people around
Donald Trump who are going to be
involved in the 2020 campaign are
starting to think about what is the
campaign going to be which Democrat
might be we be running against what is
our approach to the debates going to be
all of this stuff is starting to get
going except the entire 2020 campaign is
going to be under a black cloud of
multiple investigations into criminality
into potentially impeachable offenses
like putting pressure on the Justice
Department to block the AT&T time warner
merger which i talked about on today's
show and we just have to concede that
this is what it's going to be now and
analyze the election on that basis
because anyone who's hoping for this
stuff to go away and for it to just
become Trump running for re-election
against whoever it's just not happening
okay the House Judiciary Committee has
now opened up a broad-reaching
investigation focused on obstruction
this includes the James Comey firing
this includes Michael Cohen in some ways
this includes so many different things
81 81 people and entities including the
White House
the Justice Department senior campaign
officials Trump org officials even the
president's sons Don jr. and the
slightly less bright if you can believe
it
Eric Trump everybody is wrapped up into
this thing so yeah Trump's going to try
to get himself reelected but as that is
all going on there are going to be
investigations they are all going to be
paying untold thousands tens of
thousands or even hundreds of thousands
of dollars in legal fees which is great
for the attorneys by the way as is often
the case and as they are trying to get
Donald Trump reelected these
investigations are going to continue and
they are going to become extraordinarily
oppressive in the sense of getting in
the way of Trump and his cronies and
this is exactly what should be going on
okay
think back to Benghazi for a moment
eleven hearings on Benghazi did Hillary
Clinton refused to appear did she say
yeah I think I'd rather answer questions
in writing and that's it no Hillary
Clinton showed up and she was strong and
she sat there for what was it eight
hours 11 hours no wrongdoing was found
if anything Hillary Clinton was asking
for more diplomatic security which a
republican-controlled house refused to
give her at the time Donald Trump has
used every possible means to avoid just
answering Robert Muller's questions
arguing that Robert Moeller is simply
not a credible investigator that he to
try to impeach Robert Muller's character
to try to argue that robert muller has
not been properly appointed or that that
there is some kind of jurisdictional or
constitutional or legal issue with
robert muller as special prosecutor Rudy
Giuliani has done TV PR lawyer and gone
on television to try to lobby public
opinion in such a way that I guess maybe
could have prevented Donald Trump from
having to answer questions and
ultimately negotiating that questions
would be answered in writing as opposed
to Donald Trump getting in front of
Robert Moeller and answering the
questions directly
I because Trump iliza uncontrollably
Trump lies uncontrollably and it's
extraordinarily likely that he would
have perjured himself so now that that
one piece has been sort of satisfied
with Trump's inquest in writing answers
it is the tip of the iceberg there
Democrats are now in power Jerry Nadler
who Trump at some point called fat
something I don't even remember some fat
guy or whatever he is now heading this
up and this is going to be a shroud of
suspicion and a constant weight on the
shoulders on the backs of everybody
participating in Donald Trump's
reelection and it's going to be
absolutely fantastic and I look forward
to it because it's what should be going
on responses are demanded within two
weeks we will see who figures out legal
mechanisms to not even respond the
requests outline a sprawling
investigation seeking documents
communications as I mentioned commis
firing possible pardons offered the
Trump officials Trump's finances and
foreign governments catch and kill
payments involving the parent company of
the National Enquirer and Trump Trump's
campaign contacts with Russians and
WikiLeaks I was talking to some other
progressive hosts the other day and we
were saying what do we think so let me
backtrack a little bit when Donald Trump
was first elected we all saw a spike in
interest in the political world in
general and then we saw that as the
questions about the legality of
everything that had transpired continued
to grow we saw more and more interest in
programs like ours and I was talking
with some other progressive hosts and we
were saying is this just the new normal
like how long is this escalated level of
interest where the david pakman show
YouTube channel is gaining six to seven
hundred subscribers a day and we've had
more than 700 or so new paid members in
2019 alone is this going to continue or
are things going to quote settle down
and the consensus was that this is the
new normal this is the new normal
American politics these investigations
are going to continue not infinitely
right nothing goes on forever but
indefinitely with no particular endpoint
at this point in time this is just a
part of it the other element of this is
the Jared Kushner security clearance and
I'm showing you a letter from
congressman ted Lieu from california the
Jared Kushner security clearance issue
needs to be investigated in a very very
serious manner and this is a letter that
ted Lieu wrote to outline to Donald
Trump's Attorney General William Bar why
he believes that there must be an
investigation a criminal investigation
opened into how Jared Kushner ultimately
obtained his security clearance and to
sort of sum it up for you concisely what
we now know is that Jared Kushner was
deceptive or extraordinarily ignorant of
the truth I think is a way we can say it
in his original financial disclosures
and disclosures related to his security
clearance foreign contacts were not
disclosed all sorts of entanglements
were not disclosed and the decision that
was originally made on Jared Kushner
security clearance was he shouldn't have
won he just simply should not have a
security clearance we now have two or
three different versions of of
explanations some of which conflict with
each other as to how Kushner ultimately
got that security clearance every single
one of them in some way connects the
nepotism cronyism and the bullying of
Donald Trump you'll remember that Ivanka
Trump has previously said that Donald
Trump was in no way involved in
obtaining the security clearances that
she and Jared Kushner ultimately were
given that appears to be a lie Ivanka
Trump should be subpoenaed and forced to
answer questions about it and now ted
Lieu is just saying what should have
been said for a long time this is rising
to the level of possible criminality the
Attorney General the Justice Department
should look into it but do any of us
think that Donald Trump's hand-picked
attorney general is going to look into
whether Jared Kushner was given a
security clearance he shouldn't
had by Donald Trump the guy who
appointed William Barr to begin with
obviously not obviously not so ted Lieu
is doing the right thing here and that
we need to know about this stuff he's
putting it on record why we need to know
about this stuff and all of the evidence
here and maybe he is trying to build the
case if William Barr doesn't look into
it that this is a form of aiding and
abetting by the Attorney General of
criminality for which there is
significant evidence I don't know if
that's the approach I don't know if we
will ever get a serious investigation
into exactly what powers forced a
security clearance on Jared Kushner but
good for congressman ted Lieu for
demanding that investigation good for
congressman Jerry Nadler for starting
his investigation into a wide reaching
obstruction and other possible crimes
and we'll see where it goes but if
nothing else this is the new normal
this is what we're going to see up to
and through the 2020 election will it
help Democrats or not I don't know the
answer I don't know the answer okay I'm
gonna get two super chats momentarily so
if you are interested in having me
answer one of your questions you can use
the dollar sign at the bottom of the
chat window if you're interested in me
opening up the phone lines become a
member at david pakman.com slash
membership we do have a coupon code
available right now the coupon code is
64 66 0 for6 0 if you use that coupon
code when you sign up but you will save
60% and I will be one membership closer
to opening up the phone lines this is
all in celebration of reaching six
hundred thousand YouTube subscribers and
rapidly approaching 700,000 I think
we're all ready yet like six hundred and
two thousand and I want to thank Glenn
Turner Glenn Turner just signed up at
david pakman.com slash membership using
the code 64 60 that's one we are looking
for 10 when we get to 10 new members
I'll open up the phone lines for you
six one seven eight three zero 4750 okay
Jackson wants me to do a deep dive on
debt and deficit explain modern monetary
theory and why debt isn't necessarily
bad
yeah we've interviewed some experts on
this issue like stephanie kelton who was
a burny economic adviser back in 2016
we've interviewed who else did we
interview on modern monetary theory
Pavlina chernova who's really good on
that issue and i'm open to doing more on
debt and deficit III also the problem
with debt and deficit is if I overdo the
debt and deficit stuff it starts to give
the impression that it's a bigger issue
than it actually is when what I really
want to point out is that it's not
actually the serious issue that
Republicans and even some Democrats make
it out to be
but maybe we will Jackson do a long-form
on debt and deficit meredith white sent
a $5 supercharged do you think the RNC
encouraged a primary to have a back-up
plan if Trump gets impeached or is very
clearly not going to win that's a
possibility but it's a double-edged
sword because pushing a primary against
Trump a primary challenge against Donald
Trump can also weaken Trump if that
challenger loses but ends up running as
a third party and when we looked at last
election 77,000 votes in three states
are all that put Donald Trump in the
White House their pot the possibility of
giving enough Republicans the idea that
hey I would vote for this guy or gal if
they ran third party potentially losing
Trump the election it's a risk so I
think that that it's sort of a
double-edged sword Meredith
Sam Dean sends a ten Australian dollar
super chat g'day mate how do you feel
about Australia issuing a passport to
Julian Assange do you believe will make
a deal with America to deport him is
there an example you know of that aids
your opinion you know I haven't even
heard about this yet let me see if I can
look something up about that Australia
Julian Assange passport let's see what
there is
IIIi completely missed this story let's
take a look at a associate or a Reuters
article about it you zoom it out a
little bit this is a crazy it's it's a
savage level of zoom Australia has
confirmed that Julian Assange has a
valid passport a key development for the
WikiLeaks founder who fears that Ecuador
seeks to end his asylum in its London
embassy and extradite him to the United
States the new passport which would
allow Assange who is in failing health
to return to Australia was issued in
September last year but remained
unreported until Saturday his previous
passport had expired that is interesting
now I wonder how he gets from the
Ecuadorian Embassy to somewhere where
that passport would be useful ah there
it is
senator Rex Patrick of minority party
center Alliance who has taken up Assange
as cause in Parliament asked Department
officials if they had talked to the
United States about safe passage for
Assange if he left the embassy
James Larsen the department's chief
legal officer said he was not aware of
any u.s. proceedings against Assange and
so there was nothing to discuss I don't
have a record before me of what our
engagement with the United States is
specifically concerning mr. Assange that
is interesting yes so I don't know I I
think that that's I have no idea I mean
quite frankly I just don't know Sam if
there may be a deal with the United
States to deport Assange but I will look
into it and report back to you that's an
interesting development okay let me say
thanks to Kevin Zuniga Kevin Zuniga has
become a member at david pakman.com
slash membership that is two out of
three I'm sorry two out of six two out
of ten two out of ten on the way to ten
new members at which point I will open
up the phone lines also want to say
thank you to Craig Stanway Craig Stanway
has signed up using the 60% off code
this code ends tomorrow by the way Craig
Stan Way has himself a nice new David
Pakman show membership shiny and out of
the box for only two dollars and 40
cents a month why because he applied the
coupon
code 64 60 which saves you 40% next
super chat is from you you by Jesus
EBIT Jesus okay do I think capitalism is
inherently exploitative well in a sense
the concept of capitalism is taking
labor adding it to raw materials and
creating something which can then be
sold for more than the sum of its parts
in other words taking two dollars of raw
materials and paying someone five
dollars for their labor and selling it
for ten dollars instead of the seven
that went in so is it exploitative yes
in a sense it is exploitative the
question of whether it's a fair level of
exploitation in exchange for the
business owner establishing the means of
production is how is that surplus split
if poor working conditions and meager
wages are provided to the worker in
exchange for their labor then it's by
definition exploitative in a way that we
shouldn't accept and that we need
government regulation to deal with if we
take that surplus and we divvy it up in
a way that is fair provide steady income
for employees in conditions that are not
unsafe or exploitative then we can say
that maybe that's a good arrangement and
I think that that's basically the view
of social democracy so the answer is yes
in a sense it is exploitative
but the question really requires more
analysis than that to fully discuss what
alternatives would be better or what
alternatives would be worse Jason
LeBlanc
has used the join button to become a
YouTube channel member this is something
new that not every YouTube channel has
access to we have it so if you look
below the video window just down there
you'll see a button that says
join that allows you to choose YouTube
memberships that start as at as little
as a dollar ninety-nine a month
I think they top out at what do they top
out at I don't even remember actually
let's see if I can pull it up what do I
want I guess I want my own YouTube
channel let's take a look I think $1.99
maybe $24.99 or is it maybe it was
$49.99 okay let's see if I can put it on
screen for people okay so here it is
oh my own livestream is being promoted
on the channel so there's this join
button and if you press it only owned
brand accounts can be used to join
channels on YouTube okay so I'm clearly
logged in in a way that it does not
allow me to show you but anyway that
join button shows up below the video
window
not every channel has that we do why I
don't know we were selected for this
beta and you can join on YouTube and and
we are counting that towards the target
of 10 so so far we have glen turner
kevin Zuniga craig Stanway and jason
leblanc
that's 4 out of 10 new members why do i
say i will only open up the phone lines
if we get new members because opening up
the phone lines cost money we have a
service that we use that allows us to
have people in a queue with caller ID so
I can mark people as good callers bad
callers adversarial callers who I go to
first almost exclusively and when you
have 30 40 50 60 people holding every
minute that those people are holding we
are paying for that because they are on
the phone that can start to add up so
that's why when I do the live streams I
say if we get 10 new members I will open
up the phone lines if people want to
call in we're not talking about a lot of
money let's make it happen 10 new
members and then I will open up the
phone lines for you and take callers at
6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 ok let me go back now
and complete our discussion about the
call for an investigation into Jared
Kushner's security clearance one of the
interesting things that congressman
ted Lieu sites here is the second
paragraph where he says mr. Kushner and
Ivanka Trump have both apparently lied
in various public interviews and in
statements saying that the president
never directed John Kelly to grant a
clearance for his son-in-law in an
interview on ABC News's the view on
February 8th Ivanka Trump said the
president had no involvement pertaining
to my clearance or my husband's
clearance 0 we now have reason to
believe that that was not true and that
would be a reason that we would
immediately want an investigation into
that as ted Lieu points out lying to the
public
though disgraceful and unethical is not
a SPO fact oh I think it means if so
facto a criminal act
lying on one's sf-86 questionnaire for
national security positions however is a
federal crime punishable by up to five
years in prison
it was previously reported that mr.
Kushner had to submit at least three
separate addenda detailing over 100
omissions including the infamous June
2016 meeting he attended in Trump Tower
where Russian agents offered dirt on
then candidate Hillary Clinton he also
failed to report his meeting with
Russian ambassador Sergey kis lyac and
the head of Russian owned bank
Venetia Nash accom Vanessa Akana Bank
I'm struggling with that one
so we've got to get this guy under oath
and we need to figure out how far do the
lies go and how extensive is the
deception because at this point there is
simply no question that he would not
have gotten a security clearance were it
not for someone's interference was it
Trump saying it to Kelly maybe not these
guys are slick so when Ivanka says my
dad never said anything to John Kelly
about it could have said it to someone
else who said it to John Kelly could
have said it to someone else who made it
happen and got it up the chain of
command we don't know they're very slick
with the way that they deceive and
distort so I think that this needs to be
a top priority and this is a national
security issue okay this these are not
public vendetta's
against Jared Kushner or Ivanka Trump or
whoever when we have people that buy the
normal course of establishing who should
have a secure security clearance are
determined not to be deserving of one uh
and then they get one anyway
that's a national security issue and
Jared Kushner could well be in the
pocket of the Qataris he could well be
in the pocket of the Saudis and if you
care about national security if you care
about law and order you have to demand
an investigation here and I hope that we
do ultimately get one okay let me get to
a couple of other super chats and
different things
garrets seeped shaped has become a
YouTube channel member thanks Garrett
thanks Garrett that is number five okay
so we're looking for ten new members
today and I'll open up the phone lines
we are halfway there option one is
hitting the join button right below the
video window that'll give you options as
inexpensive as a dollar ninety-nine a
month second option is to go over to our
website wwlp.com and then use the coupon
code sixty four sixty okay the coupon
code sixty four sixty expires tomorrow
and it will save you 60% off of the
membership of your choice it's not the
low low introductory rate of 60% off
once you establish a membership at a 60%
discount you keep it for as long as you
want okay membership provides you the
daily bonus show only available to
members and also membership is our
number one source of funding membership
has allowed us to weather the
unpredictable rise and fall of YouTube
revenue dating all the way back to
YouTube ad pocalypse and membership is
just a really great way to support
programs that you think are valuable so
if you do value the show and you want
the phone lines open today get a
membership at WWN pakman.com I will
Thank You profusely like I have thanked
Jason LeBlanc and
shaped and Craig Stanway and Kevin
Zuniga and Glenn Turner tonight's five
new members so far and if you are
interested in the phone lines being
opened let's make that happen
gr gr sends a $10 super chat the hi
super chat of the evening says half
Pakman I say no I say do the whole Trump
toilet flush or draw a square on the
floor with chalk and lure him to the
trap with a Big Mac how does that make
you feel
Congress write love gr I still after all
these years never have even the
slightest idea what gr is talking about
but he has been a great supporter for
many years so thanks to gr with peace
and love don't know what you're talking
about but I absolutely love it
mr. simple truth asks am i familiar with
international relations theories like
realism liberalism constructivism and so
on which one do you prefer for
international relations analysis you
know I'm not familiar enough with that
I'm not familiar enough with that so I'm
not really in a position to comment
intelligently what I do want to see is
international relations very short
introduction is there a very short
introduction for international relations
there is okay when I don't know much
about a topic one of my first moves is I
will get one of these very short
introductions and I've read probably 15
or 20 of these and they are a really
good whoa that is very very zoomed in
they are really good introductions to a
lot of different topics they are very
dense in general so let's see if we can
look at the beginning of this one they
are typically written in pretty dense
language but they give you and usually
like a hundred pages a really good
introduction to a topic so like I
recently read the one on stoic
philosophy I recently read the one on
organized crime and I find that when I
don't know much about a topic and I'm
wondering how to get into it the very
short introductions can be really useful
so maybe I'll grab that one appreciate
the question okay J CPP is a new YouTube
member that gets us to six we are now at
six new members during the stream when
we get to ten I will open up the phone
lines phrenic 32 is it moral for middle
or high school teachers to directly try
to influence their students political
leanings through intentionally
persuasive rhetoric it depends on your
view of morality if your view of
morality dictates that teachers should
leave politics completely outside the
borders of the classroom then it would
be immoral if you believe that teachers
should inform and educate in a way that
is going to make students the most
productive members of society possible
and by productive I don't mean economic
productivity but I mean good people
moral people people that are good people
to share the planet with then I don't
see anything inherently immoral about
about that the problem is one person's
politics are another person's
disinformation and how do you establish
some kind of policy that is objective
and that is where these ideas of leaving
anything political out of the classroom
come from the problem is how do you
teach history without a political bias
one way or the other
implicit or explicit how do you teach
philosophy how do you teach economics
without such a bias I simply don't think
it's possible
Joshua Carr great to see Joshua Joshua
recently was involved in a lot of really
great stuff with the David Pakman show
and he's a a David Pakman show all-star
he says hey David loved the show and M
as you know a huge supporter I was
wondering your thoughts on gear on your
store the Trump ones I know you dislike
ad hominem attacks thoughts on if the
shirts are ad hominem okay let's take a
look at them so I'm gonna go to the
David Pakman show
store and we can look at this together
let's see here okay so let's take a look
at these one by one and see if they are
at homonyms here is the if Ivanka
weren't my daughter t-shirt this is not
an ad hominem and that I don't think
it's an insult is it's just a a quote
Donald Trump once said that if Ivanka
Trump weren't his daughter he would he
would consider dating her so I don't
think that that one is an ad hominem and
that one looks really really good in
this blue color so that one I think is
not an ad hominem let's take a look at
the next one this thing called nuclear
weapons okay this shirt is yet another
Donald Trump quote this thing called
nuclear weapons like lots of things are
done with uranium including some bad
things
that's a summarized Donald Trump quote
if quoting someone is ad hominem well I
just don't think it is so I don't think
that one counts as ad hominem and then
we have another one here very stable
genius this is also just the Trump quote
so no Joshua with peace and love I don't
believe that these are ad homonyms
because they are all just quotes of
Trump we're just quoting the president
and if that's ad hominem I don't know
how you make that case so I am now
comfortable saying no those shirts are
not ad hominem Ariel Fernandez says do I
think Florida Georgia and Texas will
become blue states I think that they
will be swing states I think oh sorry
I'm this is an on screen I think that
they will be solidly Google Florida
already is Georgia and Texas I think
will become reliable swing states within
a couple of election cycles JC PP sends
a dollar which I really appreciate
Ron Jackson is a new member Zack
Hanratty is a new member and Ariel
Fernandez is a new member that now gets
us to eight we are at eight out of ten
new members if you want the phone lines
open today okay I will open the phone
lines it's almost ready to go it's the
click of one button to open the phone
lines if you want to call in and have me
take some phone calls we just need two
more new members my advice and
Who am I to give advice except that I
sort of know about all of the different
options my advice is to go to WWE at
muncom pick any membership okay I don't
care which membership you pick apply the
coupon code sixty four sixty okay we at
the David Pakman show reached six
hundred thousand YouTube subscribers
over the weekend huge milestone huge
milestone for us and to celebrate until
tonight at midnight we have the coupon
code sixty four sixty available that
coupon code will drop any membership
yearly monthly your choice by sixty
percent okay so let me do the math for
you you take a $6 a month membership you
subtract sixty percent that's two
dollars and forty cents a month that's a
damn good deal for all the content that
we put out if you want to get an even
better deal
switch to yearly you take a sixty dollar
a year membership you apply the coupon
code sixty four sixty that drops the
membership to twenty four dollars for
the entire year okay two dollars a month
for 150 or so YouTube videos and
anywhere from eight to twelve live
streams a month that is a damn good deal
and quite frankly if you can afford it
and you don't think that the channel is
worthy of that I don't know what you're
doing here if you hate the channel fine
you're here to troll I don't expect you
to be supporting the work we do if it's
unaffordable that's totally cool we do
the show for everybody we do this so
everyone can access what we do but if
you like what we do and you can afford
two bucks a month and you're here today
by all means take advantage of this okay
and if we get just two more only two
more new members I will open up the
phone lines and that will be very very
exciting for a lot of people every time
I do it we get some people who are angry
with we with me we get some people who
want my advice we get people wanting
relationship advice which I'm glad to
give
having absolutely no expertise in that
whatsoever so let's make it happen
okay let's make it happen and it's gonna
be a very very exciting evening I can
assure you of that
Zach Han rad Rati says I'm curious if
Jeff Bezos really has all the money he's
worth or if most of it is tied up in
Amazon and how that works in terms of
him paying taxes well listen Zach in
terms of him paying taxes this is why
any serious plan to tax the rich has to
go after capital gains because people
like Jeff Bezos are not making the
majority of their money via wages and
when aoc or whoever talks about a 70%
marginal tax rate we should have that on
high incomes but if you really want to
get at the root of this you've got a tax
capital gains because what capital gains
capital gains is effectively the surplus
value that people's wages have generated
right if you own a business and you hire
people who work at minimum wage their
labour generates business income which
you then earn as capital gains and
sometimes only pay fifteen or twenty
percent on it okay so Jeff Bezos has a
lot of money tied up in Amazon stock
this is why his net worth flux
fluctuates so wildly when Amazon stock
goes up and down and if you really want
to deal with the way that a lot of these
people are making their money sorry I
just punched my mike you've got to go
after capital gains for sure Jackson
says what do you think of destiny's
argument that if taxation is theft labor
is also theft I think it's a great
argument against silly libertarianism I
haven't seen that but destiny Stephen
bonel is really good with this stuff so
I'm gonna try to check that out sounds
like an interesting argument Elias
sriracha's says what do I think about
Amazon in New York City uh you know I
have not said much about Amazon going to
New York City because of a couple a
couple reasons number one I think that
the real problem about what's going on
with Amazon is that they won by making
people bid for them with these tax
breaks all
Amazon going into New York City was not
going to have a huge impact on the
affordability or traffic issues that New
York City already has its a relatively
modest number of people who would have
been employed there would have been an
economic benefit there are also concerns
about all sorts of things going on at
Amazon so ultimately Amazon is going to
go where Amazon determines they want to
go just because a New York City has said
no it's not going to affect the Amazon
really in any way would it have been a
net gain or a net loss for New York City
accounting for everything I don't really
know so I actually thought that there
was too much attention being being paid
to it quite frankly
Miguel RIBA says I ran for board of
education in 2018 the office should be
nonpartisan but is sadly in fur
influenced by parties how should I fight
against such partisanship well there
needs to be a campaign to make it a
nonpartisan election so for example in
Northampton Massachusetts where the
david pakman show began there are lots
of races where people are democrats and
republicans but it's not on the it's not
on the ballot and it's not partisan in
that sense that's a decision the
community needs to make that's something
and I don't know whether it happens by
referendum or what but that is that's
the way to do it and I advocate for that
I think that that would be a very good
thing okay we're going to open up the
phone lines okay we're starting to get
the heel is funny he's able to actually
make me laugh out loud I like that let
me I'll get to that in a second I'm
gonna open up the phone lines because we
have so many new members who I'm going
to thank shortly 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 let's
say thanks to Caleb Seligman thanks to
Jason Goodson thanks to who else thanks
to Chris sore vari and Ethan Harper and
Roberto Suarez and Daniel Maddux and
Levi Tooker and Roger spenger and Elias
crepitus Kripa DOS I apologize and
Gabriel
Arnel Wow Wow
thank you so much for the support I will
open up the phone lines at six one seven
eight three zero forty seven fifty
people can start queuing up now
no speakerphone please please no
speakerphone and also no Bluetooth okay
let me get that set up so vibrantly
Brantley sent me 20 bucks but says that
they're just here to troll and don't
support the channel
well you supported me with twenty bucks
and I appreciate that the progressive
voice is in the the super chat saying
what are my thoughts on destiny chucking
a guy in New Zealand I didn't hear about
that
I would love to hear more about that but
I it is not something that I am aware of
and grant table go says go vegan alright
I don't know who vegan is but a message
of support for vegan all right so let me
get going here I have to there's always
this switch that I have to do in order
to get the phone lines working correctly
hmm
how can I test whether the phone lines
are working correctly let me see here
okay people heard that which i think
means that are working six one seven
eight three zero forty seven fifty let's
see who we are going to talk to first
because there are just so many people
here to talk to want to make sure that I
note everybody who calls in the reason I
do that for people wondering I make
notes about the quality of callers which
then I put into our caller ID system so
that that way when they call in a second
time I have a note that says this person
mixes it up they argue with me it's
great to go to them
this person has interesting critiques
from a progressive perspective this
person you can't hear a damn thing or
they interrupt me never go to this
person they filibuster so that's those
are the notes that I make when I pick up
on people let's start today with the
eight six four area code caller from
eight six four tell me your name and
where you're calling from hi this is
Ryan from Greenville do you hear me all
right Ryan you know what you have one of
the best connections that we've had in a
very very long time it's truly a
pleasure to take your call
well thank you very much so my main
question is concerning the House
Majority Democrats and their
announcements of them doing
investigations into the Trump in the top
administration and I'm saying my
question about that is assuming that
they actually and can they actually go
ahead and go through with that and they
do an investigation yeah depending
assuming that they find something about
the administration and like well what
would be the actual next steps in doing
something about that and they actually
come with that very good so at this
point the the new house investigation
this broad-reaching investigation that
has made 81 requests for documents and
witnesses and all of this different
stuff we are now talking about laying
the groundwork for impeachment okay so
this is we just all have to be upfront
about this that this is now these are
investigations which are meant to
explore whether there is a case for
impeachment now this doesn't tell us
whether Democrats will actually file
articles of impeachment this doesn't
tell us whether even if they did a
republican-controlled Senate would ever
vote to remove Donald Trump it doesn't
tell us any of those things but this
type of far-reaching investigation now
is to start exploring what the case
would be for the impeachment of Donald
Trump hmm thank you
all right thank you very much for the
answering the question all right thanks
so much for the call Ryan and truly
congratulations on just the incredible
phone connection we've we've not had
anything like it for a very very long
time and I you don't know how much I
appreciate it
let's go next to our caller from the 904
area code caller from nine one four
who's this where are you calling from
hey David this is Nick I'm currently
sitting in traffic on the way back to
Boston how are you all right Nick I'm
doing well and you are coming through
loud and clear which is absolutely
fantastic all right awesome oh yes so my
question is I was reading a New York
Times article about a month ago about
Elizabeth Warren's new childcare plan
yes and how she plans on paying for it
with the wealth tax and kind of an
offhand comment they made in the article
was at the
wealth tax may be considered
unconstitutional because of the 16th
amendment which basically only allows
the federal governments you levy taxes
on one's income what do you think about
this argument alright let's see I'm
gonna pull up sixteenth Amendment I want
to take a look at it myself first so
that I can properly explore this let's
take a look at that first and foremost
okay Congress shall have power to lay
and collect taxes on incomes from
whatever source derived without
apportionment among the several states
and without regard to any census or
enumeration okay so this unfortunately
so this is going to come down to a
constitutional argument where if you
believe that the government only has the
ability to do what is explicitly laid
out in the Constitution that might be a
solid argument if you believe that the
government can legally do things that
are not specified in exactly those terms
by the Constitution or Bill of Rights
then it's not a problem and ultimately
that is where the debate would would lie
and I don't I don't have the answer to
that it would be ultimately up to legal
scholars and courts to decide can that
make sense I just thought was kind of
interesting I didn't really explore it
in the article is kind of just an
offhand comment so it's one of your
thoughts on that thank you at this point
we're pretty far from passing a wealth
tax so it may at this point it's
probably 99% academic and maybe someday
it'll become a reality
all right makes sense okay appreciate
the call thank you great to hear from
you what a day with connection so far
very very good connections let's go to
the seven eight six area code caller
from 786 who's there oh boy AJ you know
what I don't know if it's speakerphone
or a bird in the background or if you're
using heavy machinery
but you've unfortunately prevented us
from going three for three with just a
brilliant brilliant phone can
tonight any early you know all of a
sudden it's much better I appreciate
whatever you did oh yeah so my question
is today I would like was that was on
CNN I think was last night like a OC was
going after taxes the tax returns tax
returns expertise there was a Republican
congressman from Texas he said no we
cannot go after individual taxes easy
losses mine or is it
it is serious about it it will is who's
serious you're saying is that is the
Republican congressman from did you
taxes or taxes Texas tax returns on this
one sorry what did you say tax attorney
taxes if tax returns
Terence okay but the congressman was not
from Texas right I think he was from
Texas I thought he was from Texas from
Erin Burnett Show last night okay and
you're saying is he out of his mind for
saying that they can't go after
individual tax returns yes okay I've not
heard any legal argument for why they
can't go after individual tax returns
okay what you think about China and
South China Sea I love I would love to
do yeah so what can we do to stop China
from attacking our democracy like China
I think we'll attack our democracy in
next twenty twenty election in why
should we stop the China I think there
are funding Republicans nothing China is
funding Republican American politicians
yes why do you think government yes
because of of the case and wall very
little so there are final Republicans to
do something about to do what what do
they want all the things to do to drop
those charges against me as a sort of
quid pro quo yes
yeah that's interesting I mean listen we
know that there is constant attempt to
interfere by
powers in our elections sometimes
they're successful sometimes they're not
the question is bigger than China it's
about having an administration that
takes that foreign interference
seriously we don't have one right now so
this is a great time for China to get
away with whatever they want
unfortunately and what's the coaches use
it to save $35 I'll go and join today as
a member
oh they've done the safe the the code to
save $35 is gone but the new code is
sixty four sixty okay so with the code
64 so you can save thirty six dollars
would you be open to saving thirty six
dollars instead of thirty five sure okay
so the code six 0fo are 6-0 sixty four
sixty will save you thirty six dollars
off of the sixty dollar membership area
and proved great I hope to hear from you
again okay before I get to the next
phone call I just want to make sure I'm
keeping up with all thank yous here
William Bristol is a new member and I
really appreciate you signing up Brian
McManus is also a new member and JC PP
is asking about webinars on how to look
at politics critically I don't know if
you're asking if I'm aware of any
webinars which I'm not or if I would be
interested in putting a webinar together
probably not I mean I would I would do
YouTube videos in YouTube series that's
more my format but webinars I'm not
aware of nor of am I likely to do any
webinars at this point in time okay
let's go to our caller from the nine
three seven area code caller from 9:37
who's there where are you calling from
hi David this is Rachel calling from
Indiana hey Rachel what part of Indiana
you're calling from Bloomington
Bloomington you know we actually just
got on TV in Bloomington I need in yep
cool so I wanted to ask and I'm here
where Ilan Omar is under fire again over
the weekend no I had
she made okay basically she made
comments mostly seeming somewhat anodyne
but still kind of referencing the do
dual allegiance to Israel kind of thing
and there this time she's doubling down
rather than apologizing there's been a
huge backlash and you know maybe it
would be better to ask you this question
if you kind of actually look up what
what's going on like I want to ask if
you think that it's more of an that
there's a bit of an overreaction to what
she's saying well I don't know I guess
what the reaction is and I'd have to see
exactly what the comments are I have to
admit Rachel I'm finding myself not
caring about Alana Maher like I don't
know what it is like there's a lot of
and I don't mean that it so this is not
to say that you're yeah I don't like
your question in any way I'm finding
that this entire thing it's like okay
she made comments that some found to be
kind of foot-in-mouth and others said
were really good critiques about the
influence of AIPAC on American politics
there was a discussion as to whether
they played on anti-semitic tropes
either deliberately or out of ignorance
people got very very wound up listen the
truth is that you can say there's a
double standard in terms of the reaction
to alon omar that people who make
different comments about influence on
American politics would not be seen in
the way that she is being seen you can
say that's the double standard you can
say the double standard is that the only
sort of double loyalty that is being
brought up is that of Jews to Israel and
the United States and we don't hear that
about you know immigrants from the
Middle East having dual loyalties to
their home country in the United States
so you can accuse both sides of sort of
double standards and and kind of
misplaced reactions and in the end I'm
finding like hey let's see what kind of
a proposal she has for taxes or for the
green you deal or something about
pollution like I'm finding myself kind
of bored with it
yeah yeah I kind of agree it's kind of
more exhausting watching the outrage
machine go and go about it going back
and forth but what seems really unfair
is that there's a lot of calls to have a
removed from the Foreign Affairs
Committee over it and I don't really
think that her comments are really all
that offensive I think she's the
language she's using is kind of toned up
yeah I think the tone deaf but I've not
listen I've not seen the latest comments
but I have not seen anything that would
make me think she should be pulled from
the committee at least not not from the
initial set of comments um III don't
think that with these recent comments
you it your mind would change it all
either okay I'll check it out after the
stream I appreciate the call Rachel no
problem thank you
all right Bloomington Indiana yeah glad
to be on television there it's great
stuff okay REI Rena Humphries sent a
donation to ask how to change the amount
donated I don't know I don't know that
you can after you've donated it Irene
Phil Runge is a new member which I
really appreciate and we will go to our
next caller let's go to where do we want
to go next just so many people holding
there's so many exciting area codes that
I like to guess at let's see what about
the let's go to the eight one seven area
code caller from eight one seven where
is eight one seven and who's this eight
one seven is Fort Worth Texas Oh
all right Franco Frye cool yeah I have
someone who just moved down there and
they like bought a mansion for $300,000
it was crazy sounds about right
yeah housing prices are relatively cheap
down here what's going on thanks for
taking my call
I was listening to your show from
earlier today and you were talking about
how debates are essentially meaningless
are there they're terrible as far as
like informing people and that sort of
thing so I just had a question in
regards to I don't have it on the
surface this may seem like a bad idea
but what is your thought on making like
taking the American Idol sort of model
and sensationalizing debates where you
actually have perhaps judges that are
well-respected in a given community who
would fact-check like you're saying
bull's statements after the fact and
then provide like a grade or a score at
the end of the debate to actually kind
of give some sort of subjectivity to it
it sounds interesting to me the problem
is no one would ever agree on who the
judges should be then you would say well
we'll have two Republican judges and two
Democratic judges and then what you're
basically just going to have is just
another layer of partisanship which is
kind of like the grades I think that
serious news organizations like PBS for
example Reuters in The Associated Press
would be more than capable of doing live
fact-checking you could even put the
debates on a five minute delay so that
to the audience the fact-checking would
really be popping up live because
they've got a five minute head start but
I think fundamentally it's a sort of
double-edged sword because you have an
audience that doesn't really want
long-form debate and discussion they
want talking points and zingers and you
have a format that only allows for that
and so you're never really going to
figure out some really deep substantive
sort of policy positions from the way
the debates are set up I mean it like 90
seconds plus 60 seconds to respond it's
like you can't even really lay out what
the issues are in that amount of time
sure yeah that makes sense to me as well
I'm just trying to figure out kind of
like brainstorm and figure out you know
ways to go about it where we would be
able to have more informative and more
long-form discussions and in that in
that sort of way too we route them out
there there's actually serves a purpose
because I agree with you that they did
seem kind of meaningless and frivolous
at this point yeah I mean here's here's
the right way it should be done and this
would require really engaged people who
have attention spans and the willingness
to actually do the work there should be
for example a 90-minute debate between
the the primaries are complex because
there's so many candidates but the final
debate
you should have 90 minutes and the topic
should be narrow it can't just be
domestic policy like that's way too
broad that includes social issues
economic issues it's just way too much
it should be 90 min
it's for example on domestic economic
policy period then you can spend 20
solid minutes you could spend way more
but then you can spend 20 solid minutes
on tax policy what policy do they
believe makes sense for taxation what
are the tax rates that there should be
how would those impact different
industries what is the purpose of
setting tax rates at a certain level who
would watch that right I mean we just
don't have a public that would actually
actually sit there and pay attention to
that oh I don't know I mean it's a surge
of podcasts these days and people really
listening and enjoying three-hour long
to form conversations I think there is a
market for that or there's a certain
subset of the population that I think
that would be down for that I certainly
would just hear you talk about oh my kid
that's a great idea I'd watch that maybe
you're right
I mean but but again remember that the
long-form podcasts even if they get a
couple million views on an episode
that's a tiny fraction of the entire
voting population and most of the voting
population is not seeking out three-hour
podcasts yeah you got me there but
listen I don't serve don't serve really
any good purpose other than just kind of
like a milquetoast version of talking
point contests sure and I agree but
that's that's disheartening to me but
thank you for answering my question I
appreciate it yep thank you for the call
really appreciate it want to say thank
you to Shawn burnstead no it's Bumstead
Shawn Bumstead who is a new YouTube
member appreciate that let's go next to
our caller from the for10 area code
who's calling from for10
hey David is Carrie from Annapolis
Maryland hey Carrie what's going on
excuse me I just had a question a bit
more general a bit more future minded
what are we gonna do about the
Republican revolution that's still going
on Democrats always being on the
backfoot
like laboring through good legislation
just to get torn down like Trump's doing
now what can we do long term to combat
destructive behavior like that
what do
specifically which bill it what what
bill are you referring to well-built the
individual mandate being repealed trying
to take Obamacare down from the inside
something that Nancy Pelosi works really
hard to get through you know it's it's
becoming a lot easier to tear down these
institutions these not institutions but
programs that take so long to build up
how are we going to find our way to any
kind of stability with anything yeah I
be listen on the one hand you're right
on the other hand Donald Trump with two
years controlling the White House the
Senate and the house all he was able to
do was suspend the individual mandate I
don't want to minimize how big of a deal
that is because it's sort of like one of
the funding sources of how this entire
thing works but I think in a way it's
not as easy as you might be suggesting
to tear down these legislations because
Trump had everything for two years and
the Obamacare exchanges are still in
place in many states they continue to
grow so I actually think it's not quite
as easy as you're representing to tear
down some of this stuff true might I add
a bit more pointed question yeah the
Newt Gingrich seemed to bring about this
Fox News kind of mentality of thinking
of whenever we're doing something bad or
something's going wrong let's just not
call it what it is so we don't have to
speak on the same reality as everyone
how do we combat that that thinking that
is just trying to throw the conversation
towards chaos constantly yeah that is I
don't have an answer for that I mean I
think at a systemic level if everybody
started learning critical thinking and
philosophy and civics at a young age
probably starting at ten we would have a
population that is much better prepared
to resist falling prey to that type of
specious reasoning and just renaming
things or calling things something other
than what that they are but that's like
a much bigger systemic issue and I wish
I had an answer about it but I don't
maybe for me it's
educational activism yeah right and I
think that saying which is we've got to
be teaching critical thinking and all of
this other stuff very early on which the
right doesn't want to do because they
know that that leads to worse election
outcomes for them naturally yeah well
thanks for having a back and forth with
me Dave appreciate the call thank you so
much hope to hear from you again via
super chat Rockley says Bernie Tulsi and
yang will do well in the debates I don't
know how long Tulsi is gonna be around I
am unsure about that and I don't think
she will do very well in the debates but
we will see let's see who else is
holding here let's go to the five one
eight area code caller from five one
eight who's this where you're calling hi
this is Ahmed
I'm calling from upstate New York hey
I'm ed what's going on I just wanted to
talk to you about an issue that hasn't
hit a US news yet yeah a bit of a
background I'm from Algeria okay so
there's been the president who's been
there for like twenty years has been air
is running again he hasn't had a public
speech since 2012 and there's like four
million people in the streets and I just
noticed that the US media has picked up
the story in a negative way but CNN
suggested pilot violent protests and
Washington Post suggesting that the
government is using force with which
neither of them is true so I just wanted
to give you a head start on a story that
might or might not get bigger in my
opinion it will get bigger much bigger
and I'm afraid of like it go in the
Syrian way that's like we're scary for
me so I just wanted to like have you
like pick up the story earlier thank you
yeah I don't know anything about it and
I will look into it and I appreciate you
letting me know great have a good one
we've got a super chat from Comp Sci law
who says blocked number five one nine
area code from Canada
I don't see any block numbers on our
system and I don't see any five one nine
numbers so I don't know what you mean
but I'm sorry I don't I don't see that
let's go to our caller from the 205 area
code caller from 205 what's going on
today hey David sorry this is Robert I'm
calling from not David Pakman Country
Birmingham Alabama all right what's
going on so originally I was gonna ask
about you on Omar but one of your other
colors already asked about that but I
just wanted to say really quick and get
your take because she's a Muslim
congresswoman don't you think that like
the GOP and the right-wingers are gonna
try to fund anything to slam her as
anti-semitic because they're doing that
to receipted to leave and they did that
to keith ellison as well so don't you
think regardless of any you know muslim
congresswoman or senator they're gonna
try to slam her as anti-semitic um
maybe yeah I mean listen they're there
there were concerns with keith ellison i
think related to louis farrakhan if I
recall correctly with Rasheeda Talib the
issue you know it's not about
anti-semitic it's what happened to she
was for a two-state solution then all of
a sudden she's not that's a pretty big
change what's the explanation that's not
making sense to me to say that you know
it's very easy and kind of lazy to just
say oh they are anti-semites there's
plenty of anti-semites on the left and
right in the United States but merely
calling people that is not really useful
it it would be better to just deal with
people in terms of the issues if you
believe they're wrong about an issue or
they are misrepresenting something then
explain that you know what I mean so
yeah I mean you're probably not wrong
that there are lots of people on the
right who you know the problem is that
it's not sincere in that the right is
filled with anti-semites so it's just a
political game that they're playing they
don't even really care
if your target is anti-semitic yeah it's
just I mean the way that I've I agree
completely is just kind of the way that
I've seen it is all of the only three
Muslim Congress members they've all
tried to claim as anti-semitic I mean
you know it's it's I just feel like
they're there they just have it's where
they want to tie being Muslim to like
being anti-semitic and you know and like
it's a part of the religion yeah yeah I
mean I think that the three situations
you're mentioning are different but I
you're probably not wrong in assessing
their motivations okay all right all
right thank you so much great to hear
from you okay let's see Irene Humphries
figured out how to change the donation
amount and has sent a nine dollar ninety
nine cent super chat thank you very much
Andrew Mills since a ten dollar super
chat says keep up the good work
thanks Andrew and Fuad says who will you
vote for David thanks for all you do
you're my personal favorite source of
information thanks again from Texas I
haven't said yet I'm not sure I mean
right now my top candidates based on
policy are elizabeth warren andrew yang
and bernie sanders not in any particular
order I think Elizabeth Warren is in
trouble in terms of her campaign has had
some missteps doesn't really interview
well but I've not yet said who I'm
supporting in the primary and Ariel
Fernandez says do I think Generation Z
will mostly vote Democratic yeah we'll
vote mostly Democratic I do think so and
I think any suggestions from the write
that that's not the case are not backed
by evidence and data which is what I
care about okay let's go to the seven
five seven area code whose calling today
from seven five seven okay me I would
love to hear your name and I'm hearing
my own voice feeding back on about a
one-second delay maybe we could do
something about that Virginia did you
say Ryan
Yeah right okay all right go ahead Ryan
what's going on all right
so I heard talking about how everything
was great again so Ryan your connection
is absolutely abysmal it's just an
abysmal connection there's a popping
noise that sounds almost like there's
popcorn popped in the line somewhere and
your volume is going from way too loud
to unintelligible so can we do anything
to improve your connection all right how
is it giving any better you know it's
not it's it's really not it's funny it's
funny but it's really not getting better
water are you exercising out of
curiosity often now we use this app
called text now okay Internet
how would you most succinctly sum up
your question Ryan do you think Donald
Trump is taking what the web says
himself to get like the book
is he taking what who said and applying
it to himself like he's taking what the
left says and applying it to himself oh
like what what's an example of that
corporatist
get the media no I'm sorry I have no
idea I'm gonna let you go it's crazy
what's going on but I really appreciate
you calling in and unfortunately to have
to end on that note I'm out of time I
really appreciate everybody who called
in members patrons people chatting and
all of that stuff I will stream again
that I promise you unless something
unexpected happens to me and I look
forward to you joining me next time